I might want to share create these with
you that I truly believe it I'm not that
law of attraction yet but I can tell you
images pictures looking at other
possibilities getting examples of other
people doing things is so so valuable I
mean it's our first way to learn it's
the mimic we see our parents typing on a
computer the kids want to do it they
want to come type on your computer they
don't even know how to use it yet it's
mimicking it's basically taking
something else somebody has done it's
the way we learn to cook you watch your
mom cook eggs or fried bacon or make
oatmeal and she's got her own recipe
guess what that's the recipe you use so
we end up with all these little quirks
and weird habits the first thing to do
is on the manifestation thing is you've
got to have some pictures and you have
property around you you have struggle
like I grew up in struggle I didn't grow
up in poverty I grew up in a struggle
even though we had an okay it was always
this idea that there wasn't enough hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because I need it I need it for
me because I don't wake up every day and
say yes let's go conquer the world now I
wake up and I need that external
motivation to match my internal
motivation when I see somebody who's
doing amazing things it makes me just
want to play a bigger game and so I hope
that today's video makes you want to
play a bigger game too because your
message matters and let's get it out to
the world so today let's dive into the
law of attraction
enjoy
this is one of the things I do first I
take a lock in on a picture bang yacht
second thing I'm gonna do is try to get
as close to that thing the manifestation
thing not the Law of Attraction but the
law of action okay first I see it then
I'm gonna try to get I'm gonna close the
distance now it took me 20 years to get
on this this Beast okay but what I could
do in between then and I hope it doesn't
take you 20 years is I've started
collecting pictures and images okay
until I could actually put my feet on
close as you can between you and the
target
so if it's a boat a plane a business
business ownership an RV a car whatever
it is okay what you want to do is take
pictures of it collect images of it okay
maybe reinforce those by looking at them
often thinking about them just playing
with it don't even worry about how to
get it
what it's going to take to get it and
the second thing is to start like
closing the distance between you and
that image could be pictures could be
images could be research it could be you
going to the car dealership and actually
sitting in the car or you know getting
an appointment to go see the house I
remember
this is insane to think this but I
remember when I
did not think
that I could get somebody to show me a
house
I remember when I was like I was Elena
and I went out late I wanted to see this
house that was for sale and I was
concerned that they wouldn't think
enough of me to even let me see the
house
so if you guys have ever struggled with
all this limited thinking okay later I
bought the house I was literally bought
the house ended up making on that house
I made like 12 million dollars or
something and I did not think when I
went into the house that I was going to
be able to even see the house
so if you suffer from a self-esteem
issue
um
are
a sense of self or Selma daughter the
other day I said man I've had
self-esteem issues in my whole life not
thinking I was good enough not thinking
I could get there I'm still doing it
today
you know I started thinking about you
know last time I was here 20 years ago
one day I would be on a boat here to
Positano now I'm thinking one day I'm
gonna be here on my own boat
what do you want to be on okay so number
one okay take a picture up too
close the distance in three at some
point you're gonna have to start doing
the math and the math for me is this
what would it take to buy this
what is the resources the beans the
coins the dollars the energy the output
the number of people I need to make
contact with and if I can't figure that
out
just figure this simple math out how did
uh he do it how did
he do it how did he do it what business
are they in
what do they do to do this how did they
get it and maybe it's just a charter
okay so nothing wrong with that okay
hope you guys do well hope you figure
out some things that really get rich in
your mind about your manifestations
about what you want what your purpose is
what's driving you to fuel you so you
can and your you and your family can
have a great life if you ever get to
post a tunnel
okay let me know rule number two is
reprogram your mind with Bruce Lipton 95
of our behavior is coming from sub below
Consciousness and we're the ones that
can't see it when we play it but
everybody else of course is uh seeing
exactly what we're doing so the whole
idea is are you living the life you want
or are you living a life you've been
programmed and answered unfortunately is
most of us are living a life we've been
programmed and and the programming comes
from other people so it's not our lives
the recent let's give a reason why
programming occurs okay the brain is a
computer most powerful computer that
humans have ever experienced but it has
parallels to computers and number one is
this
um in the old days when you would buy a
computer before they put the programs in
you could bring it home brand new
computer plug it in push start boots up
screens on and I say do something and
people well no I can't do anything so
you got a brand new computer now first
you have to put programs into a computer
before you can use that computer the
brain of a human is the same thing the
screen lights up in the last trimester
of pregnancy it's ready but there are no
programs so the first seven years of a
child's life is the brain is not
operating at the higher level of
Consciousness higher level higher
vibration that's what we talk about we
put wires on a person's head
electroencephalograph read brain
function a child up through seven is not
operating uh Consciousness except for a
little bit it's primarily operating at a
lower vibration called Theta and I said
well what does Theta I say it's
expressed as imagination so that's how
children can have a tea party and they
pour nothing into the cup and then they
drink the nothing and then they explain
how that was the best tea they ever had
or a child rides a broom saying it's a
horse in the child's mind that is not a
broom it's a it's a horse but it's
mixing imagination in reality but Theta
is hypnosis and the significance of that
is children have to learn how to become
a member of a family the rules a member
of a community the rules I go how can an
infant a young kid learn these rules
they can't go to school they can't read
the book and all that and I say you
don't have to Nature provided Theta
hypnosis so that they can observe the
parents the family and the community
just observe their behavior and download
those as programs age seven then that's
when they start to become more conscious
and engaging themselves first seven
years is programming but after age seven
95 percent of your life is coming from
that program so if you can program the
child for the first seven years and the
rest of the life of that child is
actually an expression of that program
hi I'm Bruce Lipton author of the
best-selling books the biology beliefs
spontaneous Evolution and the honeymoon
effect I'm here to thank Evan Carmichael
for featuring me on his YouTube channel
and I want to let you know that Evan is
giving away links where you can watch
the First episodes of my special Gaia
series entitled in a revolution for free
evidence making this offer to thank you
for watching this video you will find
the links in the description section
below thank you rule number three is
stay present with Joe dispenza what
happened is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition habit is when you've done
something so many times that your body
actually knows how to do it better than
your conscious mind
it's a habit so people wake up in the
morning and they run through the same
routine every single day
and the routine is mapped out
neurologically in their brain
if they
have the thought of the coffee maker
they make the choice to go over there
they do the thing to make the coffee
they have the experience of drinking it
they feel the emotion associated with it
that becomes a pattern it becomes more
automatic it becomes second nature so we
have a series of these redundant
patterns then and in time we lose our
free will
to a set of programs and the body is
programmed into the predictable future
based on what we've done in the past and
that's how we lose the free will to a
set of programs
so that habituation is the predictable
future and that's the known
and other people wake up in the morning
and they romance their memories of the
past they they think about the problems
that they have in their lives and those
problems are connected to certain people
and certain objects and certain things
at certain times and places and since
the brain is a record of the past the
moment they remember that problem
they're thinking in the past
and every one of those problems has an
emotion that's associated with it
so the moment the person feels unhappy
the moment the person feels fear the
moment the person feels unworthy the
moment a person feels sad now the bodies
in the past
because thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being
and so it's that thought and that
feeling it's that image or that memory
and the emotion it's that stimulus and
response
that's conditioning the body to become
mind of that emotion and now the body is
so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
that that person is creating by thought
alone
and the body is reliving the same past
experience over and over again and if we
can't think greater than how we feel or
feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
if we believe that our thoughts have
anything to do with our destiny then our
future is going to look a lot like our
past
so that familiar past also is the known
and so what we discovered is that if you
could teach a person
to when their bodies sitting in a
meditation as an example
and it's off schedule
it's used to feeling angry at eight
o'clock in the morning because it
watches the news
the person experiences traffic every day
they get 11 o'clock they check their
emails and they start judging other
people you know there's a there's a set
of familiar emotions that person has
been living by we discovered that if a
person can sit past
that memory that they can sit past that
emotion that causes them to get aroused
to get frustrated to get impatient
that's the emotion that causes the
person to quit and they have this
conclusion that they can't meditate or
they can't focus or they have ADD it's a
story they tell themselves about the
past
we discovered though that when a person
sits past those
those thoughts that say I can't it's too
hard I'll never change I need a brain
scan there's something wrong with me
it's my mother's fault
and they're curious to see what's on the
other side of that thought when their
body gets aroused and frustrated instead
of giving up and saying
um
I have too many things to do
that they actually learn a way to settle
the body back down into the present
moment
and it's David versus Goliath
and every time we can become conscious
that we get emotional we get frustrated
get impatient and we settle the body
down we're executing a will
now that's greater than the program and
the body is no longer a mind the person
is now becoming conscious of their
unconscious self and it takes an
enormous amount of energy
it takes an enormous amount of awareness
to stay present because to stay present
to be in the unknown that's when you
can't predict the future and that's not
when you're remembering the past and the
unknown in the program that we have is
biological creatures is a scary place
it's better to run from the unknowns
than to hang out in it rule number four
is stop negative thoughts with Eckhart
Tolle whenever
you know relationship
one side of my mind is like this is not
gonna work out blah blah and the other
side is this it's gonna work out no yes
no and all day long seriously I'm doing
something and in my mind they're gonna
let you off no they're not gonna lay her
off no they're gonna let her off no
it seriously comes to a point of losing
my mind
sometimes but sometimes I know it so
strongly so I can calm myself down so I
just wanted to ask you how can I know
what's the right answer
what's the voice of intuition like how
do I know the voice of intuition instead
of this fighting okay okay well I
believe
many people recognize your question in
thank you
it's a pattern in the human mind and
perhaps in you it's stronger than in
some who knows
but it's in in many people's minds
uh
so it's of course the the answer is in
and this is your challenge
is not trying to figure out which of
these voices is the right one that's not
it
it's to discover within yourself
that space that is not the voice
that space of awareness
so that can only you can only practice
that
while it happens
there's that voice
and then there's the other voice
and who is
aware of these voices you don't need to
answer that question I'm just putting it
out don't answer it because there's no
answer there's only a direct realization
of it within yourself there's no
external answer because if you give an
answer that's another voice
so this is the question that you should
not answer in words so I'm asking again
who is it
in you who or what
there's something in you that is aware
of these different
conflicting voices
there is an awareness otherwise you
would know that there is a voice
now the voice is of these are thought
formations
these are energy for every thought is an
energy field and each thought formation
wants to
draw your attention
suck it up into itself come here the
other one says don't come here these are
like little
some may sound a little spooky but it's
not spooky
what you can regard a thought
almost as an as an entity not not a
physical entity but as a as an energetic
entity
and that lives there it has a it has a
lifespan and some thoughts
uh persist for a long time and certain
thought patterns are also entities that
can shift to take on one form and then
another form and another form
so you have
every thought is a little entity or
energy field
it wants to it wants your
identification with each
it draw your all your attention in
because the more tension you get drawn
in the more it grows it wants to grow it
wants to like everything wants to it
once doesn't want to disappear
so it's for you to know when this
happens
who am I
you are
are you this voice or that voice no you
are aware of the voice all these voices
and
that is the place where you go so that
from that place of aware presence
the voices are no longer disturbing you
you recognize them as only a voice this
is not important whether you go this way
or that way or whether something is
going to work out or something is not
going to work out
you don't know that
your responsibility is to be present
which means to disidentify from the
voices rule number five the last time
before some very special bonus Clips is
understand what you are with Nassim here
I mean I'm curious for someone who needs
support and understanding how to create
or attract or put something into the
world have an idea and make it a reality
faster
what would you say to that question
about alchemizing an idea and bringing
it into reality
and creating more abundance in your life
well you're right it has to do with
understanding who you are but and the
thing is in understanding Who You Are
you have to understand what you are you
see this this it's not
in your relationship to the rest because
if you're trying to manifest if you if
you're wanting to manifest already first
of all
you have to understand the mechanics on
how that happens how did it all manifest
itself in the first place like how did
you get here what what are you how did
you get here what are you how is it
working like are you working with forces
that you're not aware of is there things
that are happening that you don't know
like uh think of the electromagnetic
spectrum like we see so little of the
electromagnetic spectrum we see just a
teeny bit of what's actually there
that's happening in the field between
you and I between everything so like
becoming aware
uh and understanding the mechanics of
this experience we're having we call
life is really critical and and so at
the basis like not just in a conceptual
notion not just in a philosophical way
just in a spiritual way but like really
how it works right like what are the
mechanics so what are we working with
what are the mechanics of
what we what we are and what we're made
up of and what the universe is and made
up of and how we can navigate
who we are what we are with the the
energy and the material around us you
decided to start with the easy question
right exactly right well you know this
is something that Humanity has been
exploring for a very long time right
like what is this reality how did it
manifest what is it made of how is work
I mean that's the basis of physics
physics you know physical theory is the
theories about how the physical world
function so there's that right and then
there is certainly some kind of set or
flow or dynamic of information in this
physical world that makes it so it's
highly organized
it's highly coordinated right and
eventually it produces a person
that or an animal like some kind of
thing that's able to turn around and
wonder how it's working right right
which is non-trivial and think about
itself and can think about itself so it
has self-awareness what we call
Consciousness right and so
um you know and that part has typically
been left out of the equations like and
fair enough the first step would be like
well let's try to figure out what the
material world is made of before we add
the complexity you know it's called a
heart problem in physics the hard
problem of Consciousness right so you
know
acceptable path to like start by
understanding how this thing works
problem is that the tendency is to
divide the fields of Investigation
fracture right and and what are the
divisions what are the fields so for
instance quantum theory cosmology
biology Consciousness study you know
businesses energy spirituality and
spirituality all this stuff is like
uh all pieces that have been very uh
divided and very much subdivided like
transcends in one single field of
physics you can have hundreds of
subdivisions right of uh different
fields
um and these people are working in these
fields typically work on a very focused
point in that field and they don't
necessarily talk to the other guys in
the field right beside them or in the
and so they all have their beliefs and
viewpoints as well probably right right
and their expertise and their jargon and
and the way and their pharmacism and how
they write the math and the physics and
all this for this and so and they're not
necessarily compatible with the other
languages
um and so on and so it's very rare that
you can pull out right that you can pull
out and and see the whole together the
holistic view I like to call it right
um like with w-h-o right the whole thing
all right and and so
um and so this
um this method
of doing science has very successful
um effects in terms of getting the
details of everything
but has a large downside is that you
start to lose the picture of the whole
thing you start to lose the
understanding of the whole thing how it
interacts how it works and you start to
think that all these things are separate
right but it's not all separate it's
really not
I'll ask you a very simple question
why does your organization exist
we don't need you clearly there's plenty
of competition clearly people have
plenty of choices even the things that
you may specialize in there are others
that do a reasonably good job they might
even be better than you in some areas so
why do you exist providing education is
table Stakes everybody here does that
you can't rely on that that's why the
industry exists not why your
organization exists
that's like when I talk to healthcare
companies and say why does your
organization exist and they say to help
people be more healthy like no kidding
thank you but I know that the culture of
one organization is different than the
culture of another organization there
are cultural norms that wrap around the
sense of purpose cause or belief
great organizations understand their
just cause a cause so just
that people would be willing to
sacrifice to see the advancement of that
cause sacrifice comes in many forms it
might mean working longer hours giving
you my best ideas turning down a better
job that offers me more money to stay
here because I believe in what you're
doing and I want to see that advanced
one of my favorite examples of a just
cause is the Declaration of Independence
our founding fathers declared literally
wrote down they declared why we needed
our own country
all men are created equal
endowed with these unalienable rights
amongst which include life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness
they were never against Britain
the whole point is not to be against
something but to stand for something
Britain was simply standing in the way
of them advancing their cause and though
they won Independence there are always
finite games within the infinite game
though they won Independence
that didn't mean that they had now
provided or men are equal now the real
heavy lifting began
now let's be Crystal Clear when they
said all men are equal what they meant
was white Protestant men let's be
crystal clear
but even early on during the
Revolutionary War George Washington
understood how limiting that was and he
realized that they had to have a broader
definition so he included Catholics
he banned any organizing against
Catholics in his armies and he would
regularly attend Mass to send the right
message
sometime later we abolished slavery
and the 14th Amendment
sometime later we had women's suffrage
sometime later we had Civil Rights Act
sometime later we Implement gay rights
and you can see that we are striving to
provide this thing called all men are
equal people are equal and though we
will never actually get there we will
die trying and the obstacles may always
be different
and what a just cause is it is a vision
of the future that does not yet exist
and you will commit all of your energies
to advance that vision of the world that
you have
and the people you want to attract both
those who work there those who teach
there and both those who come to learn
there
Believe in Your Vision of the future
so much so
that they may turn down a better offices
from someone else because they want to
be around people who are committed to
building this world that does not yet
exist and every single single one of
these organizations that you run and
represent
can have different Visions or
overlapping visions of the world but you
must be clear what your just cause is
what you stand for otherwise the only
thing I have to judge you on
is superficial things it's like dating
right
it's like dating if if somebody tells me
what they stand for who they are they
talking about their character
and those are the people we want to
spend the rest of our lives with
if we do not have any sense of who they
are what they stand for what their
purpose what their cause what their
beliefs are what their values are
the only thing we have to judge them on
is how much money they make and how good
looking they are if you want to have
one way is to
you may be wasting money and that's why
we're talking
common ways we throw money away where
exactly did your money go money is
something a lot of us struggle with
check this out in a 2019 employee survey
a PWC 71 of Millennials said their money
stress had gone up over the past year it
is stressing me out and nearly half of
all respondents said that they spent
three hours or more every week thinking
about or trying to sort out their
finances and money woes don't just
affect us individually 44 of young
adults said that the money is the number
one stressor in their relationship
and check out these stats according to
Erin Lowry creator of the broke
Millennial Blog the average Millennial
graduated with 37 000 in student debt
that's in the states and some have much
more that's enough to buy a brand new
car or put a down payment on a house
maybe you're like yeah don't remind me
Jay hey I get it lots of Us come from
tough places financially and you might
be there now growing up my family
definitely was not what you'd call
wealthy for some of us the hard times
actually helped spur us on to success
here's one of the stories that's really
inspired me it's of a young man who at
14 was evicted with his mother from
their apartment and couldn't afford a
place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks Productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and the place to start is
to stop away wasting money now a little
disclaimer first what I'm going to share
with you is for informational purposes
only it is definitely not intended as
formal legal tax investment Financial or
other advice you want to consult a
qualified licensed professional for that
okay so here are those five big areas
where you can stop wasting money and get
yourself on track financially take notes
boys let's start with a super common one
that's really simple Financial expert
sus Allman says if you're buying a
coffee every day you may be literally
flushing your chance to be a millionaire
down the drain you know because after
the coffee goes through your body okay
never mind you get it anyway Omen says
that if you invested the 100 or more per
month so many of us spend on coffee in a
rough retirement account over 40 years
with compound interest you'd have a
million dollars what that's worth making
your own coffee right actually the
entire category of food and drink is a
big one not only do we spend loads of
money eating out for dinner another big
money waster people often Overlook is
lunch here's a quick quiz how much do
you think the average person spends on
lunch in a year according to Visa is it
a 520
B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends
2746 dollars per year on lunches now
check this out if instead of buying
lunch you invested that money every
month in a basic savings account over 20
years you'd have hope you're sitting
down because this is unbelievable you'd
have sixty thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars and 41 cents I'm gonna sit
down and that's just with basic
compounding interest okay so here's
another big way we raise money buying
new now here's the thing I know for lots
of us I'll be honest myself included how
we look is important we enjoy fashion
but you can continue to have your unique
look and have favorite Brands and still
spend less money on clothing here's a
way to do that I have another friend
who's into designer Brands but would
never pay designer prices her secret is
to shop at consignment stores and now
that there are lots of these stores
online there are tons of items to choose
from and you can even shop by your
favorite Brands the other month I
complimented my friend on a sweater and
she told me she got it for 65 less than
the original price and it came brand new
with the tag still attached plus
shopping Consignment also benefits the
environment because we're recirculating
clothes instead of just making more
stuff Beyond clothing there are loads of
things we tend to buy brand new that we
really don't need to for example if your
iPhone breaks you can actually buy a
refurbished one directly from Apple for
way less money and they come with a
warranty and don't get me started on
cars here's another quiz when you drive
a new car off the line but it literally
immediately loses a certain percentage
of its value what percentage is it a
five percent B 10 or C 30
the answer is B according to Carfax the
second you drive a new car off the lot
it loses at least 10 percent in value
over the first year it loses about 20 of
its value that means if you spend thirty
thousand dollars on a brand new car
within a year it's worth only twenty
four thousand dollars and the value just
keeps going down instead of needing
everything brand new look at what you
can buy used or borrow from someone you
know and that's another way we waste
money we buy things immediately we think
of it we get all excited we go online
and buy it it's like when the Apple
watch first came out and I went out and
bought one I was so stoked but no
offense to the product I discovered
pretty quickly just in time to give it
back that I didn't actually need it I
ended up returning it take it back
instead of impulse buying Bachelor
purchases if you say oh I need to buy
that whatever it may be and then go to
Amazon and buy it and then later in the
day or I wanted to get some of that
other thing I loved and then going to
Amazon or another store to buy that what
happens when you get your card statement
it all adds up and you're like whoa how
did I spend that much money I don't
remember any of that and that's because
fifteen dollars here and ten dollars
there doesn't seem like much of the time
especially when you're using a credit
card or other digital payment because
you don't see the money you don't feel
it you don't actually have that
experience of giving it away or holding
on to it instead when you think of
something you need and I'm putting need
in quotes because it might not be a real
need
want put it in your cart and leave it
there or write it down on a list don't
buy it right away then at some specified
time like the end of the week look at
your list or your cards and choose what
it is you really need that will give you
a better idea of what you're actually
spending and what you actually need
versus what you want another way we
waste money is by passing up free money
a court and you're and you're wondering
what are you talking about according to
investment advisors Financial engines
American employees leave roughly 24
billion dollars on the table every year
in unclaimed money by not taking full
advantage of their employer match on
their 401K the typical employee loses
out a 1
336 dollars per year now look if your
boss said hey we'd like to just give you
1 336 dollars per year you'd be like yes
please right I'm gonna need that in cash
but if you're not contributing the full
percentage that an employer will match
you're basically saying No thank you so
you need to stop missing out on free
money going back to your book I think
that one thing that's really really
interesting about it is the way that you
structure it around like 80 of the book
is the excuses that you you literally
tackle them one by one that was really
smart and then skill acquisition yeah so
why why that structure why excuses and
skills because of that well the excuses
are just what I hear all day from women
in DMS and emails standing in line at a
book signing it's all the reasons why
they can't do what they want to do and
it makes my head explode because it's
like what like you're not ugh it drives
me crazy so I thought it's well and good
for us to talk about the things that you
need to do to achieve this stuff but
none of this matters if you don't have
this foundational
like presence of mind to get out of your
own way and to stop using that as a
crutch for why you can't do what you
want to do if I get Flack for anything
in this space it's the idea that I tell
women that anybody can accomplish
anything and I really believe that to
the marrow of my bones because there is
no reason that I should have the life
that I have the business I've built the
being on St like I shouldn't have any of
this this is working every single day
for the last 15 years to achieve the
thing that I want to achieve you had
said something recently or maybe it was
on your Instagram where someone said
like how do I become a speaker and you
were like speak everywhere everyone that
go everywhere
that people like oh I would love to be a
speaker but I can never talk like you
and I'm like I spoke at Old Folks homes
I spoke because they can't run away by
the way if anyone needs this tip the
people laugh I'm like no it was for real
mops groups which is mothers of
preschoolers they exist all over the
country I'd speak at the opening of an
envelope and I was horrible like my
first speeches it was this maybe
somebody was like
and it's so embarrassing and you know
your hands are shaking and I had note
cards and I keep the videos on YouTube
because I want people to see the
progression of what a decade looks like
I've done it so much I didn't even need
to do a keynote right now I got you I
can make it up
um but it didn't start that way it was
so many years and so much effort and the
problem is people don't they're like
well I can't because or here's the
reason why I'm like yeah me too I had
all those excuses and it didn't mean
that making the decision to move forward
suddenly it got easier if anything
making the decision to move forward is
harder like because now
um John Maxwell said this to me the
other day he's like which is the most
name dropping thing but I was
interviewing him on the podcast we're
not like you know having a slumber party
but he said
um movement causes friction always and
so it's you it just because you make the
decision to move forward doesn't mean it
you know now we're now we're doing it no
now you've got all kinds of other
problems so excuses were really
important for me to tackle just because
I I think love my girls but women
especially like we need to call BS and
you need to have someone get in your
face and say like with all the love in
my heart this is not this is not real
this is something that you've decided to
cling to because it justifies why you're
still in the same place when you have a
goal in your head it's not even a goal
it's a fantasy it's a dream when you
have a book like this you can call it
your goal book and you write out your
goals and you go through I'm just about
to take you through bit my bit stage by
stage you go back to that but you can
look at it you can touch it you can just
make it real so remember if you do not
write out your goals as a plan and write
out how to accomplish them you don't
have a goal you have a wish you have a
dream you have a Daydream if you want to
go get a pen get a nice little book like
this you can do on your phone too you
can make a document in your future
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's my rug oh hang on
a minute
hey I got ten dollars here there you go
you go well that's not my goal but you
said I want more money and I learned
this when I used to work with women who
were infertile that come and go you know
I just want to be pregnant I want to be
pregnant so bad if I was just pregnant I
go well as I look at your notes you've
been pregnant six times I know I keep
miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal and whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have a relationship goal my relationship
is wonderful we grow in loving and
respect each other and you can have a
health goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many ways as you
can remember
you can come back any time to this and
think oh I I thought of another why and
another why so leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a Who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich
I long to be in a loving relationship
write it as if it's already happening I
am a millionaire I am in a loving
relationship Michael that doesn't make
sense it does make sense because your
mind only works in the present tense
when you say next year I'll have a
bikini body it doesn't know what next
year is
and so you must write your books in the
present tense I am I always I have I do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day you're going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and I think that's it it's not
it if you want to be madly in love right
are all the reasons why but then you
have got to put yourself in front of the
kind of person you want to share your
life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you
so I want you to really understand that
the best goal will not work if you don't
work you can have the start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success you wouldn't I don't think so
you know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12
years that's a long night 12 years and
people said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal
and he stuck it out and many people have
got so close to success and had to keep
going and you have to keep going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your girl give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
just give yourself permission
to want the things that you want and
unless you believe that you're worthy
unless that you practice love you're
never going to think that you deserve
the things that you want right so tell
the story
okay so I'm probably gonna I mean
I'll shorten it so the bottom line is
that so in
1990 I was a senior in college at
Dartmouth and my parents came to visit
from Western Michigan and we went to
this place called Simon Pierce which is
a famous glass blowing Mill and as we
walked into the restaurant I had an
experience
that you may be able to relate to and
that is I walked in and I immediately
saw this painting hanging on the wall
and it was about the size of a door only
horizontal and it was a Vermont
landscape and I was drawn into it
immediately like I was no longer in that
restaurant I was standing in that field
I could feel that breeze I'd never ever
had an experience like that with a
painting have you ever had an experience
like that with art no I mean not like
that not like that I mean yeah my sense
was that this is very atypical for you
very
so I
kind of lost it the the the the
restaurant was quiet and then
I leaned back and suddenly kind of back
in the moment I'm like I'm gonna own
this painting someday it just that was
what was right there and I looked at the
price and said like three thousand
dollars I'm like not today and I went
back and I sat down and that was it but
the painting never left my mind you see
there's something called The zygon Arc
effect I always say it wrong but it's
like there's a checklist in your brain
that when you have a moment where you're
like this is important your brain puts
it on a checklist yeah it's like a notch
yes a notch happens and now your brain
as part of the filter in the brain is
always going to be kind of scanning the
subconscious to let anything into your
mind related to that incident it can be
positive by the way like with the
painting or this is how trauma happens
too like you have this high intensity
emotional experience that notches
something in your brain and now your
brain kicks in to remember
so uh bottom line is uh I always thought
about that painting
years go by
whenever somebody would say Vermont I'd
think of the painting
I don't know why I can't explain it
never wanted a painting before was not
an art student it's going to Lost like
you're not collecting Arts no no no and
so I you know fast forward the story 10
years and my uh Chris and I are engaged
and we're gonna go up to Vermont to see
the leaves and immediately I'm like we
got to go to Simon Pierce I got to show
you the painting so we pull up to the
mill and we walk in and right in front
there is Boom a painting by the same
artist Gail Shepard and I'm like oh my
God it's here and we race all around the
place
and it's gone
and the funny thing was and this is the
way your brain works Chris was more
disappointed than I was
I literally turned to him and said it's
okay dude like it'd be weird if we're
still here after 10 years I'm gonna
track this thing down I actually said to
him you know what's gonna happen Chris
I'm gonna be able to buy this like 40
years from now it's going to be hanging
in the corporate Lobby of some building
and I'm gonna have to track down the
owner and pay like quadruple the money
they pay but I'm gonna own this thing my
mission yes so a couple years pass and
um it's my birthday I think I was
turning 30 and Chris says uh Chris gets
a couple people too
give money and he said I could buy
anything I wanted with it so I had what
500 bucks now I'm pregnant at the time
with our first kid
I should have bought a crib or stools
but for whatever reason the zeigon arc
effect takes over and I'm like the
painting so I call the mill and I get
this guy on the phone I'm like uh you
know I want to buy a kale Shepherd piece
and I said could you send me Polaroids
and he's like sure and I tell them the
budget and he goes I'll send you
Polaroids of some of her smaller things
and she's like blowing up in the
meantime right yeah she's a very very
successful Vermont landscape artist and
so I
I I say to him you know by the way
there's this one painting
and I describe the painting I'd seen
over 10 years ago and he said well that
was way before my time but I bet Gail
will know
and I'm like Gail you know Gail he's
like of course I know Gail she like
lives in in down the road
here's her number
so for two days I paced around the
apartment with 500 bucks in my pocket
driving Chris crazy because I felt like
what am I going to say to her and I must
be a weirdo I've been stalking this lady
I've been thinking about her for 10
years I can't afford a painting you know
what who am I to buy a painting like
what the hell
so finally Chris was like would you call
her I'm gonna call her you're driving me
crazy so I call her and I start talking
a mile a minute and she was amazing
and then
um I said by the way there was this one
painting and I go and I explain this
painting there's a stand of poplar trees
down the center and a big mountainscape
behind it and this beautiful blue
Vermont sky and geese flying information
overhead and
I could hear her thinking on the other
end of the line
and she said you know Mel I've done so
many large-scale
uh paintings over the years I'd hate to
mistake the one you're talking about but
I'll tell you what
what if my husband and I meet you and
Chris at the Mill at Simon Pierce and
we'll walk all around and have lunch and
I'll tell you the stories behind every
painting and if you don't see what you
like there I'll take you back to my
studio which is a couple miles down the
river and you can look at everything I'm
working on and if you don't see anything
you like there then you can go through
all my slides and see if you can find
that painting that you saw 10 years ago
and I said deal
so a month passes we go up to the mill I
walk in we meet each other she's amazing
she's like twice our age just incredibly
cool lady she's walking around as we're
walking around looking at these
paintings Rich I've got I'm like eight
months pregnant I'm realizing
these are 10 times the amount of money
that I have
I can't afford this
like I don't I don't have this kind of
money
and I'm getting like more and more into
that imposter syndrome what am I doing
mode oh my God I'm so embarrassed I'm
meeting somebody I idolize I don't
deserve to be here right wasting her
time because she thinks she's going to
get a Payday out of this correct we sit
down
and she goes now that you're sitting
down I have something to tell you
um
she said there's only been two times in
my career as an artist
that I've done two studies of the same
peace
and your painting is one of them
it's one of a pair
she knew all along she knew all along
she was playing games with you about not
knowing which painting yeah and she said
the sister piece to the one that you saw
all those years ago is sitting in my
studio right now where it's been for the
past 11 years
I start sobbing everybody's like totally
emotional her husband's like you should
have seen her when you when she was on
the phone with you it was like she saw a
ghost so we get in the car
and we drive to the mill
and when we walk in they're in the
center of this massive kind of Barn
Studio space is an easel with a painting
taped up with painters tape on it and it
was
the sister to my painting there were
slight differences not as much movement
in the grass but it was
one of the most extraordinary
experiences of my life it was as if time
suspended and I was
standing before that painting in 1990
saying it would be mine
and there I was 11 years later
standing in front of it
and then I realized oh my God I can't
afford this
and Chris walks over and he's like
what's wrong and I'm like just promise
me someday like promise me that I don't
need a jewelry I don't need a car like
just promise me you will buy me this
thing and he kind of leans over and goes
hey Gail how much for the big one and
she said um
Mel can have it for 500 bucks because
clearly when I was making it 11 years
ago I was making it for her
and so it hangs in my kitchen
it's on the back of the book
um this is the galley though right so
wait is it in the is it I think so yeah
yeah and
um it's a reminder every day that your
mind is designed to help you get what
you want
I never stop believing
that I could make it happen
and when you tell your mind what's
important to you
there is extraordinary science
that proves that your mind has a live
and ever-changing filter a live Network
that changes how it views the world What
it lets in what it blocks out and if you
program your mind correctly
and if you're clear about what you want
to create your mind will help you get
what you want I used to struggle a lot
with manifesting just the idea of it I
would watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it uh
whether it's manifesting a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
code of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
and it's too blurry you're still looking
at my face you're looking at my car
you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potential to the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your particular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth are
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as they came up with an idea
I was like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that you can
never plan all the way out there's no
way you know if you wait to have the
perfect plan by the time you start
actually executing the plan is is dead
it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe that great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you show cut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's a write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically but I just decide to listen to
it and do something on it and it leads
to something amazing
the amount of times it has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car when you buy
your new car you see that car everywhere
and then number two is trust a good
ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
Attraction people talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success what you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a speaker
in front of 70 000 people
[Music]
that big
but to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but but look I've got I've got a belly
here I've got a you know whatever I'm
I'm I am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to turn
your visualizations into reality check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there if you teach people
how to create from the field instead of
from matter they will shorten the
distance between the thought of what
they want and the experience of having
it between the cause and the effect now
think about three-dimensional reality
many people